if you're conscious of something you can
hinge policy on it in a way that you
can't if you're if it's
there are effects but if you're
conscious of it you can set up in
advance a policy we said well I must
remember not to do extra I must remember
to do XYZ one only if you consciously
see why can you set up such a policy so
there is a very clear case where
becoming conscious of a stimulus makes a
huge difference about what you can do
with it you know if we have to choose
between the first person point of view
and the third person's going to do then
I'm strongly of the opinion that we
naturalist should choose the third
person point of view when they're in
conflict yeah personally very five
things because we all go through a
process of conscious analysis of you
know whatever I'm reading the paper I'm
thinking about the paper I'm responding
to the paper and so on and so forth so
yes one needs to be very careful it's
similar to to the you can make the same
exact argument for color perception or
we know the old perception general we
know that we can be mistaken perception
therefore we should go around blind
because we can't trust it no we don't
have that option
we just don't I don't think we have it
in the case of consciousness either it's
a good thing to be careful and aware
consciously aware of the fact that there
are limits in systemic biases and all
that sort of stuff but you can't you
just can't go around doing anything
including having these discussions
without it so I'm not understanding why
all these ganging up on consciousness
very well where does that come from but
no but I mean look that it's a perennial
issue in the behavioral sciences right
should we we often have conflicts
between what subjects report sure and
our interpretations of how subject to
behaves so that's I assume whatever but
alex is getting at me he talks about
conflict between third-person evidence
and preservers and evidence and I mean I
think that the history of the behavioral
science overwhelmingly tells us alex is
right about that right to do us you you
always want that behavior yes yeah how
do we do the behavioral channel well and
a lot of different ways depending on
yeah my point was that that behavioral
check cannot do without the person's did
the person is checking conscious
involvement well that's one kind of
behavioral test you can do you can ask
me what they were conscious of their
hetero phenomenology a third person who
science
I mean psychophysics yeah depends on
many experiments depend on getting the
subject reports and perfectly good
science it's relying on their
consciousness but there's all sorts of
controls in place okay link between so
reason in the in the previous session
played a big role I think one of the
accounts became very well is sort of has
to pass through your reasoning faculty
is does it also have to pass through
your conscious faculty if you reason
unconsciously is that somehow not first
great reason yes it's the difference
between and what I mean let me say that
the reason I asked the question is not
voted on at Oracle it's because when you
say that you are immediately attaching
more confidence to consciousness that I
think is warranted on the basis of what
we already know about the degree to lock
this means okay so now okay
of course there is self-deception and
rationalization and ideology and and
other sources of misdirection where we
fool ourselves where our own conscious
introspections of what we're reasoning
are unreliable but it's also the case
that it's only conscious reasoning in
which we get to articulate carefully and
to evaluate and to to I'm trying to say
is it human who talks about sort of
turning the reasons over in your mind
and and really reflecting on them it is
only conscious reasoning where the
reasons themselves become objects of
attention when you reason unconsciously
you may be a demon you may do it very
fast but you have no way of assessing
the reasons themselves they play the
role they do covertly in effect whereas
when you reason with yourself when you
consciously reason with yourself to put
it bluntly
it's like reasoning with another person
you now have a witness and if you
recognize that sometimes the best way
you're trying to solve a problem
sometimes the best way of doing it is to
find a sympathetic interlocutor say tell
me what you think in this reasoning and
then we do that with ourselves so that
the reason that you should associate the
best reasons with conscious reasoning
just because they happen to be more
reliable in general because they have
this kind of turning over property is
that what you're saying yes and they're
more reliable precisely because they are
actually tested
in a certain way that unconscious
reasons aren't tested there they are
main orion creatures they they they are
they are subjected to a certain sort of
quality control that unconscious reasons
aren't
you